- The McDonald's coffee cup case,
the case where the aunt sued
her nephew for hugging her,
these are all examples
of the most ridiculous,
frivolous lawsuits ever,
(air whooshes)
or are they?
One of the hallmarks of the
American legal system is that
if you've been injured, you have the right
to have your grievance
heard in a court of law.
Of course, one of the downsides
of the American legal system
is that if you haven't been injured,
you also have the right to
have your grievance heard
in a court of law, but not
every newsroom or TV show
has a legal consultant on hand,
so they often leave out
key details and nuances
about particular cases.
And they have a hard time
determining which ones are which,
and occasionally these
sensational headlines
that focus only on the dollar amounts
can sometimes give people
the wrong impression
about the merits of the case.
So today we're gonna discuss
some of the most frivolous lawsuits
that actually might not have
been so frivolous after all.
(bright music)
And, of course, if we're
discussing lawsuits
that have been labeled as frivolous,
but actually might have a
kernel of truth to them,
there is no better place to start
than the err frivolous lawsuit.
That is, of course, the
McDonald's coffee cup lawsuit.
So let's start this discussion
with the story of Stella Liebeck,
the woman who spilled
scolding hot McDonald's coffee
on her lap and sued the restaurant.
Now, here are the facts,
as you might not have
ever heard them before.
On February 27th, 1992, Stella Liebeck,
then a 79 year old woman
from Albuquerque, New Mexico,
ordered a cup of McDonald's coffee
at the drive-through window.
Liebeck was sitting in the
passenger seat of her parked car
as her grandson stepped inside
to grab some cream and sugar.
Since the car had no cup holders,
Liebeck placed the coffee cup
between her knees and
pulled to open the lid.
She then spilled the entire
cup of scalding hot coffee
on her lap, causing third
degree burns on her thighs,
buttocks and groin.
- All I remember is trying
to get out of the car.
I screamed, not realizing
I was burned that bad.
I knew I was in terrible pain.
- She was actually
hospitalized for eight days
and underwent skin grafting.
Liebeck was permanently
disfigured after the incident
and was partially disabled for two years.
Some of the trial exhibits that were used
in this particular case,
shine the light on just how
devastating her injuries were.
Now, of course, Liebeck sued McDonald's,
accusing the company of gross negligence
and for selling coffee,
that was, quote, unreasonably dangerous
and defectively manufactured.
At trial, it was uncovered
that McDonald's had been serving coffee
between 180 and 190 degrees Fahrenheit,
much higher than the industry norm
and which expert testimony revealed
could cause third degree burns
in as little as two seconds.
Other internal documents
obtained from McDonald's showed
that between 1982 and 1992,
the company had received more
than 700 reports of people
being burned by their coffee
with McDonald's having settled
claims from said injuries
for more than $500,000.
In this case, the jury
awarded Liebeck $200,000
in compensatory damages,
but reduced that by 20%
to $160,000 to account
for her own negligence
in spilling on herself.
The jury also awarded her $2.7 million
based on her attorney's suggestion
to penalize McDonald's for two
days worth of coffee revenue,
or about $1.35 million per day.
The punitive damage awards
was by the discovery
that 700 people had been
previously burned by hot coffee,
demonstrating that the
company had actual knowledge
that the coffee was being served too hot,
but failed to remedy the issue.
The judge reduced the punitive damages
to three times compensatory
damages, or 480,000,
for a total judgment of $640,000.
This decision was appealed,
but the parties settled
for an undisclosed amount of
probably less than $600,000.
Now, if prior to watching this video,
you thought that this was a case
about a clumsy, greedy woman,
trying to get rich quick
over her own mistake,
you're probably not alone.
Thanks to a perfect storm
of short news reports
and outraged political conservatives
who use the case to
advocate for sharp limits
on tort lawsuits, so-called tort reform,
the general public was really misinformed
about the nature of this case.
- [Commentator] She spilled
hot coffee on her lap
while sitting in our car
and claimed it was too hot.
- [Narrator] Every day we hear about
another outrageous lawsuit.
- As a result, the general
public wrongly believed
Liebeck spilled coffee while
she was driving her car.
She was, in fact, just a
passenger in a parked car,
and that the injuries were minor.
She was, in fact, permanently disfigured.
Late night comedians in sitcoms
have also heavily parodied the case,
contributing to the false image
of this particular lawsuit.
- You get me one coffee
drinker on that jury,
you're gonna walk out of there a rich man.
(audience laughs)
- And despite what you might've heard,
Liebeck did not Sue McDonald's
for millions of dollars.
In fact, she didn't
want to sue them at all.
She originally requested only $20,000
to cover her medical
bills and lost income.
McDonald's responded with an insulting
$800 settlement offer.
Liebeck's counsel had also
offered settlement amounts
ranging from 90,000 to $300,000,
but McDonald's also rejected
all pre-trial efforts
to settle the case.
- I was not in it for the money.
I was in it, because I want them
to bring the temperature down,
so that other people will not go through
the same thing I did.
- The most that Liebeck asked
for at trial was $800,000,
and it was the jury that
awarded her $2.7 million,
which she never actually received,
because the punitive damages were chopped.
And her critics claim
that Liebeck shouldn't recover anything,
because she spilled coffee on herself.
But the jury did, in fact,
find Liebeck partially
responsible for her injury,
applying the principles
of comparative negligence
in which liability is a portion
based on how much it fault
each party was for the injury.
The jury found that Beck was
20% at fault for her injury,
and her compensatory
damages were reduced by 20%,
the amount that she was at
fault, but in the past decade,
the Liebeck case has
received renewed attention
in the form of the 2011
documentary "Hot coffee"
and a 2013 retro report video
from the New York Times.
But the false perception
about this case continues
to this very day.
- That Stella Liebeck needed
to defend a reputation
is the saddest piece of this whole story.
- But now what do you think,
completely frivolous or
is there some merit to it?
Let's move on to the next
case about the famous man
who was trapped in a phone
booth and hit by a drunk driver,
but sues the phone company.
As you might recall, the
1980s were a unique period
in our history when people
wore parachute pants,
and MTV actually played music.
That was also when the
tort reform movement,
which claimed America was under assault
by unscrupulous lawyers,
bringing frivolous lawsuits
first began to pick up steam.
And few were as instrumental
in cementing this image
of out of control lawsuits
into the American consciousness
than president Ronald Reagan,
but more on that in a
moment, because in 1974,
Charles Bigbee following a
night shift as a custodian
in the city of Los Angeles
used a public telephone booth
to call his girlfriend.
As the two spoke,
Bigbee saw a car driving
erratically towards him,
but while bystanders and a man
in a neighboring phone booth were able
to get out of the way,
Bigbee's phone booth jammed,
trapping him inside for
the near fatal collusion.
And this is how president
Reagan described that case
in a speech to the American
Tort Reform Association.
- Now it's no surprise
that the injured man sued,
but you might be startled
to hear whom he sued,
the telephone company
and associated firms.
That's right.
- Reagan claimed that this loony case
was an example of a broken tort system.
Sounds pretty bad, right?
Well, it might surprise you to know
that Reagan left out a few
key details about this case,
which would not be the first time.
- A few months ago, I
told the American people
I did not trade arms for hostages.
My heart and my best intention
still tell me that's true,
but the facts and the
evidence tell me it is not.
- So here's what president
Reagan actually left out.
First, two years prior, a driver
had destroyed a phone booth
that had been placed
in the identical spot.
Now the phone company replaced the booth,
but didn't include a
guard rail or a warning,
and the replacement phone booth
had a malfunctioning door.
Accordingly, the phone
company was on notice
that the placement of the
phone booth might be dangerous,
and didn't take what most would
consider reasonable measures
to remedy the risk.
And contrary to Reagan's implication,
Bigbee did not merely
sue the phone company.
Bigbee sued everyone he felt
had contributed to his accident
including the alleged drunk driver,
as well as the horse racing track
he believed served the
alcohol to the driver.
And this is typical of lawsuits
where you name all of the parties
that you believe are responsible
and let the facts take
the jury where they will.
And the jury can apportion faults
among all of the different defendants.
And, finally, Reagan left out
just how badly Bigbee was injured.
Bigbee had to have his right leg amputated
four inches above the knee.
And while his left leg required
skin grafts to be saved,
Bigbee would eventually
require an artificial leg,
a wheelchair, and a knee
brace for his left leg.
And because insurance
would not cover everything,
Bigbee's unpaid medical bills
amounted to more than $1,500,
20% of his yearly janitor salary of 7,300.
Bigbee was physically unable to work
and became severely depressed
and was hounded by collections agents.
But in the end, frivolous or not,
Bigbee settled for a mere $25,000
with the alleged drunk driver paying half
and the racetrack vendors
paying the other half.
But since this is America,
and we love our cars
almost as much as we love our guns,
let's talk about the supposedly
frivolous case of the man
who won $1.25 million
after stealing his own car.
This is a case that you
just read the headlines,
and it seems completely insane.
Man steals his own car
and wins $1.25 million.
Well, reading below the headline reveals
a harrowing story of discrimination
and police brutality.
In 2015, Dr. Lawrence Crosby,
then a 25 year old doctoral student,
was fixing a loose molding on his car.
A woman witnessed Crosby,
who was wearing a hooded
sweatshirt at the time,
fixing his car and assumed
that he was trying to steal the car.
She proceeded to follow him
in her car from his home
to the university before she
called them police to report
that she saw a black man
in a hoodie steal a car.
In the arrest video, Crosby
can be heard telling the police
that he was trying to fix his own car.
The police dash cam video shows Crosby
getting out of his car with both hands up,
holding a cell phone in one hand.
Officers approached Crosby
with their guns drawn.
Police then ordered Crosby
to get down on the ground.
And when he did not immediately comply,
a group of officers rushed Crosby
and threw him to the ground.
Crosby said that the
officers piled on top of him,
proceeded to hit and knee him.
And as an officer screamed
to stop resisting,
Crosby, who had his own dash
cam video, can be heard saying,
"I'm cooperating, Sir, you're on video."
That's an FYI.
Officer's quickly learned
that Crosby owned the car
and was in good standing.
And even though Crosby had
not actually stolen a car
that belonged to him,
Crosby was still arrested and charged
with disobeying officers
and resisting police.
To repeat, even though Crosby
was cleared by the police
for stealing his own car,
the police still arrested
him for resisting arrest
for a crime that he, in
fact, did not commit.
A judge later throughout the charges,
and the following year,
Crosby filed a civil lawsuit
against the city of Evanston, Illinois,
citing false arrest and excessive force.
In the suit, Crosby demanded that the city
and the arresting officers
pay at least $50,000
for compensatory and
punitive damages, fees,
costs, and such other relief.
In January 2019, the city
council voted eight to zero
to settle with now Dr.
Crosby for $1.2 million.
After the settlement, Dr. Crosby
stated that he was working
on mending his reputation,
having found himself often
defending his actions
and explaining what happened that night
once the case became a
now original headline.
And it makes sense.
If you just read the headlines,
one could have gotten the
wrong idea about what happened,
but moving forward, Dr. Crosby
said that his first steps
post settlement would be
holding an implicit bias forum
for students and faculty
at Stanford University
where he earned his undergraduate degree.
Okay, fine.
You've probably heard about
police brutality before,
so that one might not be that surprising,
but have you heard the one about the aunt
who sues her 12 year
old nephew for $127,000,
because he hugged her?
Well, there's an old saying
that when it comes to family,
blood is thicker than water,
but in the rough and
tumble world of litigation,
it's not that uncommon
for aggrieved relatives
to sue one another for personal injury.
But what is uncommon is when
the plaintiff is an adult
suing a very small child.
And so goes to the story
of Jennifer Connell,
the woman dubbed the aunt
from hell, who sued her nephew
for $127,000 over a
birthday hug gone wrong.
You probably heard some
of the facts of this case
when the story first went viral.
In 2011 an Upper East Side
aunt attended a birthday party
for her then eight year old nephew, Sean.
The precocious lad was riding around
on his brand new bicycle,
his first two wheeler,
when he saw his beloved aunt.
And when he spotted her,
Sean, who was technically
the son of a cousin,
but refers to Connell as his
aunt, dropped his new bike
on the ground and ran to
his aunt at full speed.
He leapt into her arms exclaiming,
"Auntie Jen, I love you."
Auntie Jen was caught off
guard by the leaping nephew,
causing her to fall and break her wrist.
Two years later, she sued young
Sean for hundred $127,000.
Now, if this sounds ridiculous,
you would not be alone in thinking so.
When word of the case broke out,
people blasted the aunt who
was a human resources manager
on social media, dubbing
her the aunt from hell
and the worst aunt
ever, and Auntie Christ.
And the news media also piled on,
portraying her as a greedy money grubber,
bringing an inherently
ridiculous case against a child.
The trial didn't help her image.
Auntie Jen testified that her
injury harmed her social life
by making her unable to hold
the plate of hors d'oeuvres.
She further testified, quote,
"I live in Manhattan in
a third-floor walk-up,
"so it's been very difficult.
"And we all know how
crowded it is in Manhattan."
She argued that young
Sean had been negligent
when he jumped into her
arms and broke her wrist,
and, therefore, that she
was entitled to $127,000
as compensation for her medical bills.
Now, the jury disagreed deciding
that she deserved zero compensation
after a mere 20 minutes of deliberation.
Now this seems like a textbook case
of overzealous litigation.
Well, here's the rub, and hold on,
because it involves both legal
nuance and insurance law.
I know everyone keeps asking
for more insurance law
and extremely nuanced legal points,
so, you know, here you go.
Under Connecticut law, she
literally had no choice.
Auntie Jen first submitted her claim
to the homeowners liability
insurer of Sean's parents.
In response, the insurer offered her
a mere one dollar settlement offer.
And when Auntie Jen wanted to
litigate her damages claim,
her attorney's informed
her of an inconvenient fact
about Connecticut law.
It's illegal to name a
homeowner's insurance policy
as a defendant in a personal injury case.
The only way she could get a
homeowner's insurance policy
to pay her medical bills
was to get a judgment
against the person who injured her.
So, regardless of how
silly it might've appeared
to outside observers,
Auntie Jen was required as a matter of law
to sue the party that
she thought injured her,
which in this case means
suing a young child.
Auntie Jen did not win her case,
but just because a party
loses a lawsuit doesn't mean
that it was filed without any legal basis.
A minor can be held liable
for injuring another
under Connecticut law.
In 1960, the Connecticut
Supreme Court had held
that a 17 year old girl
could be held liable
to her minor siblings
arising out of her negligence
in a car accident.
And an outlining the legal
standard of care for minors
who injure third parties,
the Connecticut Supreme Court wrote,
"A minor is liable for
injuries negligently inflicted
"by him upon another.
"It is true that in determining
the negligence of a minor,
"the law applies to him
a standard of conduct,
"which will vary according to his age,
"judgment and experience,
"but the law does not grant
him a complete immunity
"from liability for his
torts, even in negligence."
So this lowered standard of
care for minors is consistent
with what happened in Auntie Jen's case.
At trial, the judge instructed the jury
that had Sean been 18 at
the time of the incident,
he probably would have been expected
to act like a reasonable adult.
However, because the boy
was only eight years old
at the time, the jury had to consider
only what a prudent eight
year old boy would have done.
And on that basis, the
jury held that young Sean
was not liable for any damages.
After the case, Ms. Connell
appeared on the Today Show
with her then twelve year
old nephew to clear the air.
She explained that her
relationship remained sound
and she deeply regretted that
Connecticut law forced her
to take this route.
- I was informed that
Sean had to be named.
I was never comfortable with that.
- As for young Sean,
he stands by his aunt.
- Sean, what do you want
people to know about your aunt?
- That I love her and she loves me.
- Either way, this will probably make
for some awkward family
reunions in the future.
But you can tell that sometimes
what you see in the news
can be misleading, or it might
just be half of the story,
but not with today's sponsor Morning Brew.
I've actually been subscribed
to Morning Brew for forever.
It's one of my absolute
favorite newsletters,
and it's awesome that they
wanted to sponsor this channel.
Morning Brew, if you didn't
know, is a free daily newsletter
delivered Monday through Sunday.
It gets you up to speed on
business, finance, tech, and law
in just five minutes,
and it provides a fantastic quick survey
of the most important
issues while being witty,
irreverent, and informative.
And did I mention it's completely free?
It tells me how much
my stocks are going up
and how much everyone
else's crypto is going down.
Yesterday, for example, learned
about all the crazy stuff
going on with the Britney
Spears conservatorship,
that high schoolers have a
right to cuss outside of school
according to the Supreme Court,
and that the Chinese
government is shutting down
the only free newspaper in Hong Kong.
It's basically exactly the mix of news
that I'm actually interested in,
and it's one of the few
emails that I actually open.
So, Legal Eagles, this one
is a complete no brainer.
Morning Brew is completely free,
and it takes less than
15 seconds to subscribe.
Just click on the link in the description
to get Morning Brew for free.
And not only will you get a newsletter
that you will actually read,
but you'll actually help
out this channel too.
So, click on the link in the description
to get Morning Brew right away.
So do you agree with my analysis?
Leave your objections in the comments
and let me know if there
some other lawsuits
that are frivolous or seem
frivolous, but aren't.
And check out this playlist over here
with all of my other legal reactions
including a whole video about lawsuits
that really are frivolous.
So, click on this playlist,
or I'll see you in court.